hey welcome because everyone's still
alive
we could call let's do this leave you're
in nineteen year old why throwback to
Felix and mine says wedding it was truly
beautiful see I understand this one it's
my wedding I get it
I totally get it markiplier wasn't
invited I'm joking I'm joking
Jake Paul I him really hey my stop any
good why would you say that I'm pretty
sure we all hate you
Wow what a comeback huh the internet
general consensus everyone should love
each other everyone should love with
himself Jake Paul I don't really like
myself why would you say that why would
you say something so bald yet so stupid
stop right that gamer I see you're doing
your part than set have I reacted to
this I believe it I can't remember good
job
that's a big P P behavior now you can
keep scrolling thank you
have you cleaned your penis yet top
comment when sending 10 dos which I'm
too lazy size can put anything aside can
put anything what was I put haha that's
lovely ladies and gentlemen we got him
the Internet calling everyone a sip 2011
Felix saving up money so he can see a
girl he met online
listen up here Cochise kuchi gamers stop
stop making fun of me let the past be
past PewDiePie saying he found nether
rape
minecraft pros listen I'm a biker bro
I'm a Minecraft in betterment stops
whirring stop the update came out two
days ago so you're a pro because you
know of a 2-day update dumb alright
first dummy ninny second dummy MIDI
y'all dumb [ __ ] re you all said
it in my last video you were like oh he
didn't pick up the nether right it was
end you confused me I'm really smart
I'm really very intelligent all right
listen I'll do an IQ test I'll do it
right now just to prove a point because
I'm tired of people saying I am NOT Isis
too difficult do it spongebob
teaches Patrick how to make memes first
you take a funny
you need the last two bars is funny
without it I got it today I'm gonna tell
you how to make jokes now huh petition
for Felix to host and I in my class why
would I do that what would be the point
should I sit like this instead yeah I
can do that
why is this funny hey guys petition to
have Marcia scare pewds while he records
his next she did alright she already did
it sorry let me take this away she did
it in the video don't make me come there
now and it's like the least threatening
hey guys it's me remember to be nice to
each other I have no legs I have to sit
like this we must never forget pills
nizam we must never forget
it's a beautiful Korean tires she could
go so fast I think that's the most
amount I've ever spent on a video I was
like this is crazy I'm buying a car for
a video meanwhile mr. beast now it's
like alright I'm buying a car for a meme
those are strange times
Marcia fanart pewds fan it looks just
like me you really nailed the thingies
the thing is check out the Luigi field
bye
alright the joke is Omer surprise guys
I'm actually extremely tall god damn I
feel huge honey I'm home honey I get it
because I play Minecraft I'm not gonna
lie
probably some of you don't understand if
you didn't laughs whoa oh I feel like
I've reacted to this am I in my head or
something big peepee god damn I'm gonna
show you guys just how powerful I am
all right this was the first thing I did
when I landed at the airport in Italy
and saw my future wife what's up mother
smash like I'm making a yoga video at
some point dude last week can we pull
that up I saw this last week and I mean
I've seen the episode that this relates
to now it's the comic book episode it's
so good I love that that makes me happy
kack kack Ewing is that his name so cool
I knew it's Jojo but I didn't know the
episode happiness noises I liked it guys
I just realized something
this is young PTP an old PewDiePie same
photo just 50 years apart this is one of
those I took a photo myself every day
for 50 years no you can't just post
memes that I don't understand it makes
fun of me haha
triangle Rick tech stop stop Felix this
is an IKEA sub it's Finland sub yeah
well what is IKEA have then that's that
you can immediately associate with the
country nothing except alright you have
movement role and I don't like movement
roller by the way it's not hot it's not
sexy and I can't factor it what's the
point
manga anime Netflix adaptation up just
shut up shut up shut up shut up I'm sick
of you making fun of me goddammit can
you bring back book review
notice how I've done them I just don't
call them book review I'll make one all
right fine I'll make one which books
would you like ignore then intend to
switch here that's been in there that's
not mine it's my wife's boyfriend's
there's a lot of great books I read that
I would love to talk about if you guys
are interested I'll do it
beautify we built you a gaming PC Nani
she says Christ well that's say damn its
massive dude what do you mean it needs
to be perfect
that is the foot Linux how do you not
know how to creeper foot look like
linda's tech tips not the gamer oh by
the way I am subscribed now I'm
subscribed now Linda's fans by the way
and Bell let's see I hit the bell PC
arrives at PewDiePie's Wow new sext oh I
get it okay I think it's on its way to
me I'm pretty sure
so upcoming unbox video when you build a
custom creeper PC for thousands of
dollars in Pierce doesn't even make I
mentioned say it
I've already did I just did check it out
click on the timestamp let's go it's
time for love why god damn if you guys
have nothing to do watch Jojo it's good
don't watch my video it's not worth it
watch children dude I love I love that
jacket with the pink straps that'd be
dope to me dude the Bulge stuff got damn
alright pewdiepie when he plays 10% of
any game I've seen enough I'm set dude I
would sip so hard for deal
he's my queen that's peak physique right
there ladies and gentlemen nearly two
years ago
and it's still so crazy that I bump into
it have I reacted to this I feel like
I'm having a brain aneurysm sometimes I
yes I'll admit it sometimes I peek on
the reddit it happens sometimes I can't
help myself
and I know I've seen it but I don't know
if I reacted to it why does it look like
I'm luring her in with the candy like
hey why am i walking around carrying
candy what's your high
it's five three you were wearing high
heels or felix short that's impossible
you can't even make me look short that's
impossible
I'm extremely tall guys yeah like that
I definitely feel all right when you see
someone that looks like Felix from
behind but turns out it wasn't him it's
Apple shots related to science
sorry kidding me that's funny if you
didn't laugh that you're not a true bro
and that's the fact if you didn't laugh
then you must be like 20 or something
cringe made epic PDP hoodie very epic
actual memes trending around whatever
the felix reviews in meme review wait
why what what are the actual memes never
heard of penis music until he reviewed
it well then you're welcome
people are genuinely confused where I
get my memes from did they're fed
straight into the brain through my penis
generally happy oh my you okay there
buddy felix starts nervously playing
with this wedding ring when it talks
about record the bang in this fight dude
that's not it
listen it's not an unreasonable fear to
have I think it's pretty obvious we all
have that beer no matter who you are
Ricardo could jump out any moment me
after trapping two spiders in the
plastic container fighter didn't wait
they fight I mean I knew that I knew
that I'm hip I'm cool I'm down with the
kids what is happening lately have you
felt the I'm different RNA I don't know
what's wrong with me I'm scared help me
ever since I cut my hair smash like if
you want me to play Animal Crossing
alright gamer it's coming apparently you
can't record with these I have to get
another one I'll ask my wife's boyfriend
if she has one if she yes
Oh wit the head wobbles did
that's sake that's kind of hot honestly
I'm sorry if this sounds rude but this
guy sort of looks like you Joe Ted oh I
haven't seen this episode damn it
I'm gonna tell him don't you dare come
on guys come on guys I can't stop it
Felix this is blue base color with
yellow stripes instead of his default
white base his psycho has Jess yes all
right I'm lunching I'm watching
something ought to go right now
whoa that's insane holy church of what
glorious my god is beautiful the ancient
texts confession for what that's great I
need to make this I just can't be
bothered
only Council of what they're sheep you
make sacrifice very nice why even the
glass did what
oh my god what I could go through the
mouth glorious God can I have it I want
it I made it a while ago but forgot to
post how do you forget the pole
something so glorious my god why they
make my peepee feel things I've been
trying correct
I've been some not to get correct i
beaten minecraft and i beaten jojo
petition for felix actually read pdfs he
finds so he can actually understand the
story i understand the story fish go
blub blub like come on guys french the
wipe you do you life you lose book
review Friday
this whole subreddit spin deep wait this
is Jojo damn can't wait for that episode
who knows maybe pity primers will become
the new currency me he's back gamers
he's back my god he's the richest gamer
alive 15 hoodies nine shirts three pairs
sweatpants one pair of socks coat
headphones book cup chair for obvious
reason you realize you can never own
another shaker why Oh unless he goes
forth he's too powerful it needs to be
stopped
this is lizard lava by the way huge
shout out man I think you have a youtube
channel he did a video with Cyrus great
suddenly will like get into this
description play Terraria get lots of
views stop at one third of the game stop
at one third of the game I beat it it's
subjective
you understand its what it is one-eighth
come on
alright when the next update comes out
I'll check it out again
what the hell is this height you tube
high school what a good day I don't go
to the club but he would like my hair
Oh God all right is that I'm gonna have
just what I couldn't even read that
you're not going in with that haircut
okay sad sad devastating nice nice yeah
so I actually didn't know this because
I'm a-gonna idiot these have like they
have these insane version where if you
turn them on
I didn't know how do I not know this you
get insane babes I don't know how it's
possible but Sonia sounds like 10 times
better with these bad boys that's all
I'm saying
guys I have a theory oh my god I get it
oh my god I'm just like you kids Oh Mike
I get it
Felix probably won't recognize his old
picture of him yeah that's all because I
have legs still then in that picture
that's how you know oh god here we go
wait whoa that scizor okay you guys are
talented I'll give you that actually
funny tweet well done
what should you say after sex my
boyfriend that's fully whatever you do
don't remind Felix how short he was
compared this is such BS dude hey let me
show you they did me dirty man like yeah
they're tall and all but like this is
what's happening in this photo do you
understand I'm swear I would never lie
about my height like this is this is the
photo Felix I'm not the neighbor's kid
also Felix I watched
that's money I mean bruh 69 okay that's
the sex number what's the emoji for my
current hair leave it in the comment
that's it for this week's Lavoie check
out a little why shaker cup if you're
feeling gay and I see you guys tomorrow
check out the merch simp Nautica $5 to
charity water that's not what the
charity the ocean foundation and I see
you gamers tomorrow don't hate all
haughty blah you know what's big pee
pees do they play PewDiePie's pixel ings
of course pixel ings is creature
collecting game I'm the primary
shareholder over a Brazilian players
have downloaded and it's got a perfect
score it's safe to say it's the most
popular game of all time PewDiePie pixel
aims it's awesome
deal with it deal with it
you
[Music]